" Permettez-moi tout d’abord de
souhaiter la bienvenue à tous ceux,
beaucoup plus nombreux
qu’à l’ordinaire,
qui n’ont jamais siégé
dans notre hémicycle. "
Pour LCP, c’est toujours un évènement
quand il y a des élections législatives
et quand il y a des nouveaux députés
qui arrivent à l’Assemblée
et là il y en a beaucoup parce
qu’on a 75% de l’Assemblée nationale
qui a été renouvelée,
ce qui est énorme.
Sur 577 députés, il y en a 431
qui sont nouvellement élus.
On a un groupe majoritaire
La République En Marche qui est pléthorique.
Il y a 308 députés
qui sont élus en 2017.
Ce sont des macronistes
ils sont élus sur le seul
programme d’Emmanuel Macron.
" J’ai une responsabilité.
Cette responsabilité, c’est aussi
d’appliquer le programme d’Emmanuel Macron
et puis après je serai un élu
constructif donc j’apporterai aussi
ma pierre personnelle à cet édifice
qu’est le programme d’Emmanuel Macron. "
Il y en a beaucoup
qui n’ont jamais fait de politique
et qui ne sont jamais venus
à l’Assemblée nationale.
Et là, il y a des images exclusives LCP
où on a pu nous avoir l’autorisation
de poser notre caméra et
où on voit ces députés rentrer
avec toute la fraîcheur qu’ils ont
parce qu’ils ne sont pas politiques vraiment.
" - J’étais assistant parlementaire,
mais avec un sénateur…
Là, c’est la première fois,
je n’ai vu ça qu’à la télé.
- Est-ce que ça vous dérange de
nous prendre en photo tous les 3?
- Ça fait beaucoup plus grand à la télé.
C’est vrai que c’est tout petit en fait. "
Il y a Marine Le Pen,
il y a Gilbert Collard,
mais en fait ce qui est le plus étonnant,
c’est pour moi ce groupe d’Insoumis.
Tous les journalistes sont
autour d’eux et ils avancent,
ils déambulent comme ça,
on sent qu’ils prennent un plaisir fou.
" Résistance! Résistance!
- Et à la fin c’est nous qu’on a?
- Gagné!
- Gagné! "
Et puis nous on a la chance, LCP,
d’avoir notre caméra à l’intérieur,
où on les découvre
en train de se préparer.
Parce que c’est vrai
que les Insoumis souvent,
ils ont un peu la chemise
qui sort du pantalon,
ils sont un petit peu débraillés
mais là c’est vraiment
jour de fête.
" Si tu veux la faire super bien,
tu fais 2 fois le tour, tu vois.
Alors là, voyez, il faut faire
un petit creux pour que ce soit parfait.
Sinon ça fait trop rigide.
Vous voyez?
Il faut que ça ait un faux
air romanesque, légèrement négligé. "
Et puis après, il va se tourner
vers un député qui est très proche de lui,
qui est Alexis Corbière
et il va à son tour l’aider
à faire son nœud de cravate
parce que j’imagine
qu’Alexis Corbière a du mal à le faire
ou n’a pas l’habitude de le faire.
Ça, c’est une image
qui est effectivement assez marquante
et assez touchante finalement
de ces premiers pas de nouveaux,
néo-députés à l’Assemblée nationale.